How did Paul Swigga get its name? That is probably the most common question I get asked,
and the short answer is without very much thought at all. So I was starting out as a pen tester,
as a computer hacker. And in those days, this was before Twitter, anything like that, to go and
learn and get information, you tended to hang out on forums, bulletin boards, mailing lists,
that kind of thing. And you'd often be making posts to ask questions, that sort of thing.
Everyone said, you need a handle, don't post under your real name. Computer hacking was a bit
disreputable, people didn't really understand it, didn't even know it was legal. Even your employer,
who was paying you to do this as a job, didn't really want to be associated with it in public.
So they needed a handle. And this was before the modern web. And pen testing was mostly aimed at the
network and the infrastructure layer. And one of the terms you talked about a lot was the term port.
And one of the tools was a port scanner, the scanner network to find open ports. So in about 10 seconds,
I thought, well, port is also a drink. And instead of scanning, you say swigger, port swigger,
is a bit of a silly pun, it means somebody drinks port. And that was it. I didn't expect it to become
known, to become associated with me, to be anything like a business, which it eventually did.
And a long time later, we eventually hired some brand consultants and asked them, you know,
is port swigger, is this the right name? Is this working for us? Is it a bit too silly? Do we need
to grow up? And they went and thought about it. And fortunately, they came back and said, you should
keep it because it's different. Everybody else has names like net and sec and tech in their name. And
there's nobody else like port swigger. So at least you stand out, which is what I wanted to hear,
because I wasn't going to change it anyway.
So how did Burps We start? Well, I was a pen tester just getting started,
learning the tricks. I was also lazy, like many pen testers, and I wanted to automate my job.
An awful lot of pen testing is laborious, repetitive, error prone. You just want to find a way to speed
it up. It isn't that much fun. And there weren't any good tools around, particularly for web testing.
So I decided to write my own. My initial focus was on automating customer tax. So I had ideas for
placing payloads into an HTTP request in different places, iterating over different types of payloads,
sending all the requests quickly, capturing results. And that was the first decent web testing tool I
wrote, and I called it Burp. And that eventually evolved into Burp Intruder. And then along the way,
I also wrote a proxy, a spider, repeater tool, various other bits and pieces, and put them all together.
And that became Burp Suite.
So I did Burp Suite get its name for no real good reason. So I was in those days, I was in the habit of
writing disposable tools every few days, start on work on some of the little tool or other,
run with it for a bit, get bored, do something else, and I tend to give them all random names
without any thought at all. And one day I was working on this tool and I called it Burp. And
that just ended up being the one that I ran with and carried on working for years and years. I had
no idea at the time I started that it would last longer than any of the others, but it did.
So I've Burp written in Java, more or less by accident. You probably see a pattern emerging here.
I was a hacker who could code. I wasn't a real software developer. I'd never worked with anybody
else and never had any training. When I started learning to code, I taught myself C, C++. And then
when I wanted to make tools with a user interface, I started using C Sharp. C Sharp was the new shiny
thing then and seemed pretty good. Worked with that for a while. One day, I think I got a new laptop
at work and I ended up losing my copy of Visual Studio. Visual Studio wasn't free back then. You
had to pay for it. And I think I originally installed it off some MSDN disks that were lying around the
office and I couldn't find them. So I went and I think I went and try to download a pirate copy and
couldn't find all the bits. And anyway, I was too tight to pay up for an IDE. Eventually, after a couple of
days, I got a bit frustrated and just thought, well, you know what? Isn't Java the same as C Sharp? I'll
just maybe try Java next to my next language. Downloaded NetBeans. NetBeans is free. Got up and
running about an hour later. I was writing my first Java tool. Actually, in C Sharp, I'd already built
a simple tool that was similar in concept to Burp Intruder. And the first thing I did when I got
started with Java was to just recreate that tool because I thought it looked interesting and I wanted
to carry on working on it. So I just started again in Java and that ended up being Burp. And so Burp
was actually my hello world program in the Java language. So today we have real developers who know
what they're doing, working on the code base. And if any of them look at some of the really oldest
code, I wonder why it's in such a mass. It was because it was literally the first code I ever wrote
in Java. When did I realize that Burp Suite could be a successful business? Well, for a long time,
for many years, it was just a pure labor of love. I was just doing it for fun. I enjoyed thinking about
difficult problems, building solutions to them, writing code and sharing what I built with other
people. It also made my job more efficient steadily over time. So I got this virtuous circle going where
I'd spend some time working on Burp, write a feature that made me more efficient so I could do my job
quicker. So I had a bit more time to work on Burp. But that was just really good fun for ages.
Burp was doing pretty well. It was nowhere near enough money to live off, but it was just,
it was a really nice little hobby to have. And then one day, we did some consultancy for a huge
software company who were considering buying a web vulnerability scanner. And they asked us to look
at all of the scanners that were out there and assess them to see how good they were. And I was
leading that job. And so I did that. My conclusion was, these scanners really suck.
All kinds of bugs that were really commonplace. You ran into all the time, pen testing,
they didn't find them. So I just got to thinking, well, seriously, how hard can it be
to write a half decent web vulnerability scanner? So I decided to do it and build my own.
A few months later, it went into Burp Suite as a scanner. And literally overnight, that put a zero
on our revenue. Everyone, loads of pen testers are lazy. They love the idea of having a vulnerability
scanner built into their toolkit. And it was really successful. And that made me think, well, I can
probably live off this. So soon enough, quit my job. I was able to put all my time into Burp.
And eventually start to build the team behind it. And never look back.
So what's my favourite Burp Suite feature? There are probably two answers to that. There's an answer
from the heart and an answer from the head. And the answer from the heart is it's probably the manual
testing simulator. So this was a really silly joke feature that I put into Burp a long time ago. I
can't even remember writing it all. Why? I must've just been bored one day and it was a bit of fun.
And what it basically does, it simulates the activity of a manual tester by sending traffic to
the website that you're attacking, you're targeting, just to make you look busy. And the idea was if you're
on a, on a pen test and you need to take some time off to have a lunch or meet a friend or go to the gym,
where you just leave this running. And if anyone's looking at the firewall logs or the server logs,
it'll just look like you're, you're still busy. So just released this for a bit of fun. It turned
out quite a lot of people are using it. We had, we get occasional bug reports from users who really
missed the point. They said they've been running the manual testing simulator all day and it hasn't
reported any issues. We occasionally, one time we got say a Burp customer contact us to say they'd
engaged a pen tester to test their website and they were looking at the server logs and they could
tell he was just running the manual testing simulator. And they wanted us to look at the logs and confirm
this so they could take it up with them. And we kind of said, well, we probably shouldn't get involved.
This is between between you and him. So that's the kind of, that's the fun feature that I think is
the coolest. The more serious answer, the answer from the head is definitely Burp collaborator.
So Burp collaborator is absolutely incredible. It's, it finds invisible bugs. It finds asynchronous
vulnerabilities that are already triggered after you finished your testing. It just finds issues
that are completely undetectable in the application's behavior that you can observe as a, directly as a
tester or as a scanner. This really was a game changer. So traditionally there's just been this
dichotomy between different approaches to scanning. So SAST or static application security testing,
traditionally people say, well, you know, it has high coverage. It finds a lot of bugs. It also has
huge number of false positives, generates a lot of noise. Whereas DAST, dynamic scanning has lower
coverage, doesn't find as many bugs, but then it tends to be more accurate. It doesn't have as many
false positives. You take your choice. Well, Burp collaborator, we call it OAST, which is
out-of-band application security testing. This has way better coverage than DAST because it can see
inside the application and it can trigger vulnerabilities that have no visible effect
on the application's behavior, but it's also pretty much free of false positives. So if we send a payload
to exploit, say, SQL injection containing an obfuscated domain name, if something on the server side does a DNS
lookup on that domain name, we can be pretty certain that that payload was processed in a SQL query and
that it was vulnerable. So it's a fantastic step forward in the whole paradigm of dynamic scanning.
So that's the real answer. The overall coolest feature of Burp Suite, I would say, is Burp collaborator.
So who is Peter Weiner? Well, he's actually a good friend of mine. It's not quite his real name.
He's a guy who, he's a pen tester. Many years ago, we were working together on site and he went to
up to a door and buzzed the intercom to be let into the building and said his name. And the
person on the other hand, other and misheard and they said, Peter Weiner. And we just had a bit of a
laugh about that. And it just stuck as a nickname. And we started to call him it. A bit later, I was
working on the Burp spider feature where you would submit forms and send inputs. And when I needed a
name, I just decided to use Peter Weiner, half as a little tribute to him, but just mostly to wind him up a bit,
bit of a joke. Peter Weiner went everywhere because Burp would submit this all the time when it was
when it was spidering and scanning, there were reports of complete mayhem. People with printers
where Peter Weiner's name was showing on the LCD screen of the printer. Loads of people who's helped
us was getting hammered with 10,000 emails all coming from Peter Weiner when the pen test was on.
Some people started to complain. And initially, we thought they're just being silly. You know,
we obviously knew Weiner is a euphemism. We thought it can't be that offensive because
it's a real surname, right? A while after that, we discovered apparently in North America, Peter
is also also has a double meaning for the same organ. And you put the two together and we realized,
well, actually, that does sound a bit more juvenile than we intended. But still, of course, we aren't too
corporate. We like to have a joke. And we just decided to let it let it be. But over time, we
realized some users are actually getting into trouble because of this, they would go to a close
meeting at the end of a job, they'd have to explain to the client what they've done. And the first
question the client had was why people we his name was everywhere. So eventually, we killed him off.
But the legend lives on. And Pete actually is very proud. This is his claim to fame. When he meets new
pen testers, new security testers, he's really proud to tell them that he is the original Peter Weiner.
So is it going to be a third edition of WA? Tons of readers have asked for this, and the publisher
absolutely has asked for it. The short answer is no, there isn't. There are some really big downsides
of writing a book. You do a ton of work all at once. It starts about dates. It's not interactive.
People can't discover it easily through search. And basically, I couldn't face doing it all over again.
So instead of a third edition of WA, we made the Web Security Academy. And this is online, it's digital,
it's interactive, it's completely free for everyone. It's constantly updated. We have over 150 vulnerability
labs where you can learn how to find real vulnerabilities safely and legally. So to anyone
still reading the Web Appakers handbook, now I would say this is the time to switch and discover the Web
Security Academy. What do we have against Carlos? If you don't know who Carlos is, in the Web Security
Academy, he is this person who appears in many of the labs. And the challenge to complete the lab is to
delete Carlos. And this often involves something like compromising an administrator's account, taking
control of the application and deleting the Carlos user. But seriously, Carlos is known to us in real life.
He's a very sinister individual. He's perhaps the epitome of pure evil. That's why we need to keep deleting him.
So how did I get into Web Security without a real plan to do so? When I was at uni, I studied philosophy.
I was there stuck around a long time. I was there eight years. I did a PhD. I was doing lecturing. I was
really considering a career in academia. And then I got a bit bored of it. So I needed a job. As a child,
I'd always played around with computers. I taught myself to program in basic on things like ZX81, ZX
Spectrum. So I thought, well, I'll find something I can do with computers. So my first job was a general
IT consultant. And I learned a lot about tech, but it wasn't too exciting. A lot of things like project
management, audits, security policy stuff, things like that. Then one day, I got to know some people at
the company who were doing this thing called penetration testing or computer hacking. And
this sounded way more fun. I managed to get onto a training course they were running. I taught myself
a lot of things as well. I started playing around, writing bits of tools to help me. Eventually, I got
on some actual pen testing jobs they were doing. And that was my big break. I absolutely loved it. I loved
breaking into things. I loved being devious. I loved the kick you get when you own something. It was full
of interesting challenges. I just really loved building things, solving problems, sharing, sharing
the tools that I built to do so. It ticked every box for me and I never looked back.
What was my advice to someone getting started as a penetration tester? Well, expect to work hard.
Expect to teach yourself an awful lot. I would say today, the Web Security Academy is the best
educational resource for learning web security and hacking. So I would start there. I would learn to code.
I would, you can write your own tools. You can customize other tools. You can use the Burp API to
write amazing Burp extensions to do crazy things. Writing code means you understand how developers
think and the kind of mistakes they can make. And that really helps you as a hacker when you're trying
to break in. I would spend a lot of time on bug bounty sites. Years ago, when I started, the only way you
could legally test a site for vulnerabilities was on a paid engagement where they're giving you approval.
These days, there are thousands of sites on the web that let anybody come and hack them and they will
pay you for the bugs that you find. Go to sites like HackerOne to find good bug bounty sites to work on.
I would also read the public reports of bug bounties. There are masses of write-ups of vulnerabilities
where you can see how other hackers have found them and the evidence they got and the methodology they used.
I would also form a network, go to events, make friends in the industry, share ideas with them.
But mainly, work hard, keep learning. Web security is a huge area, but it is all great fun.
So what is life like at Portswiger? Well, it's not like anywhere else, certainly anywhere else that I've worked.
Portswiger has been shaped by the formative experiences that I had in the places I worked before my career.
So my first job was in a huge accountancy firm. It was extremely hierarchical, very tightly controlled,
full of huge egos, everyone driven by status. It really wasn't my thing. I then moved to a tiny
pen testing firm, which by comparison was total chaos. It was great fun. I learned a lot from some
amazing people. Eventually, they kind of grew a bit too fast and started to lower the bar on who they
hired and it ended up not quite as good as it had been. They then got acquired by a really big pen testing
company that was a listed business, obsessed with money and financial targets and basically everything
changed. So when it came time to build the Portswiger team, I was absolutely fixated on avoiding mistakes
that I think I'd seen elsewhere. So for me, the most important thing was hiring exceptional people. So
we have an amazing diverse team. We have loads of software engineers, we have researchers, we have product
specialists, loads of writers, we have graphic designers, customer champions, all sorts of
different people. But the common thread is that we only recruit the best and they're all exceptionally
good at what they do. Other than that, we tend to minimize hierarchy. We do have some structure,
we have some teams and we have team leaders. But for us, leadership really is about enabling people
on your team to succeed. So it's not that command and control, it's about mentoring and supporting,
your people so they can do the best they possibly can. We give people a lot of freedom. I've never
seen the point in hiring a bunch of smart people and then micromanaging them. So we do encourage
experimentation, give people freedom to fail. I think that's often how we're at our most innovative.
We really, we prefer people with a low ego. We respect each other, support each other. We like to
make decisions by consensus. We share all our information across the whole business. Everyone knows
everything that's going on. We strive for excellence. We set a really high standard for our work. We work
hard. We deliver amazing things. PulseRigger is changing the world. We are generous. If you look
at the price point of BurpSuite, it's really competitive. We give away a lot of our outputs,
our research. We take a SWIG, the Web Security Academy is all free. We pay our people what they're worth,
we pay them well. We give a lot of money to charity. We're self-funded. So all our growth has been
organic. We don't have any venture capital, any private equity owners in play. That is amazing.
That means we can make the right decisions, do the right thing. We can focus on the long term. We're
not just chasing short-term profits. But most of all, we have fun. So I started working on BurpSuite
just purely for fun, not to make any money, not to be well known. Really, that has never changed.
So we're lucky. We love working on hard problems. We love sharing what we build with the world.
So PortsRigger's plans for the future. Well, it's an exciting time to be in cybersecurity. I think
it's on everyone's radar, whether it's consumers worried about their data, small businesses who
don't have the security skills they need in-house or don't know where to get help. For large enterprises,
security today is a board level issue. The world has changed essentially. Security is no longer
optional for anyone. It's an essential. So keeping the trust of your customers is imperative
if you're going to survive. And our focus is on enabling the world to secure the web. And that means
giving everyone the tools and the knowledge they need to gain that trust and making it easy and fun,
not a burden. So in terms of what we're doing, we always think big. We have huge ambitions for BurpSuite
and for our other services and outputs. Web pen testing is in our DNA. We're going to keep BurpSuite
the best pen testing toolkit that there is. We've got huge ideas for building on browser automation
to support new kinds of custom automated attacks. For the scanner, we're going to continue to innovate.
We're going to keep up with modern applications and technology, discovering new classes of bug.
We're going to carry on combining different flavors of AST, application security testing, together for
maximum effect. For enterprises, our focus is really about supporting scanner scale and also
DevSecOps and security testing in CICD. We're going to do a lot of work on cloud native
capabilities. So that BurpSuite Enterprise Edition can fully benefit from the huge elasticity that the
modern cloud provides. We're going to have more integrations with other development systems,
essentially supporting enterprises on that shift left journey as they develop security maturity.
Our research team is already the best in the world. We are expanding that team. We want to do more.
We're currently hiring for a cloud security researcher. The Web Security Academy is always
really amazing. We're going to be adding new topics, new, many more labs, new challenges and games,
that sort of thing. The Daily Swig, we're creating fantastic articles, landing quite a lot of scoops.
We want to grow the profile. We want the Daily Swig to be the place to go to get web security news.
That means we're going to grow the team. So if you're a, if you're a like-minded person who thrives on doing the
kind of things that course really does, we'd love to hear from you. Other than that, overall,
we're going to carry on having fun. It's what we do best and why not?